So, here is our plan for the project. I will
start with step one, which is reading text. Now, here is
the file I want to check for curse words. For
now, I have some famous movie quotes in here. By the
way, this file could have contained some other text, like
the draft of an email or an article you wrote. I
have named this file movie_quotes.txt. Now, if you want to use
this exact file in this program. It is available for you
to download in the instructor notes. But you should
feel free to use any other text file on your
computer as well. Okay, let's start writing code. Now,
I created a program called check_profanity.py. You could have called
it something else as well. Inside it, I created
a function called read_text, which is empty for now. Now,
I know there is this function in Python called open,
which allows you to work with files on your computer.
This function takes in the address or the location of the file you want to open.
So, on a Windows machine, I will browse
to my file, which is movie_quotes.txt. Copy its location.
Paste that. And then add the file name
I want to open, which is movie_quotes.txt. Now,
if you're on a Mac, there is a helpful document in the instructor notes for you.
That document will tell you how to get the location of this file on a Mac.
I will refer to this file as quotes.
Now that I have a way of accessing movie_quotes.txt,
I will use a function called read. So,
I will say, quotes.read. This will allow me
to read the contents of movie_quotes. So, let
me save that in a variable called contents_of_file. Let
me print out those contents. And it's also
a good convention to close out any file that
we've opened through the program. Okay. Now, I'm
going to save and run this program and see
where it gets us.
And boom. Here is that output window with all
of the movie quotes that we had read from the
text file. Now, I don't know about you. But
it just blows my mind that we can read from
a text file with only a few lines of
code. Okay, so I am back at our program. Now,
before I continue to execute any more of plan. Let's
find out a bit more about this function called open.